we'll call the meeting of
having
nine members present we have a quorum
motion to approve by schmidt ii by lang
any additions deletions or corrections
seeing none all in favor
promotion on the consent agenda does
anybody wish anything removed from the
consent
motion by gray second by mcguire to
there's a number of alternates here that
mr chairman
yes uh representative tucker could sit
for senator apprentice
and representative gruen could sit for
okay we'll adopt that suggestion
and
the department of health and human
services
has
oplc anticipate it for next next meeting
no
hey yes sir this proposal makes changes
to the licensing rules for these types
of practitioners
there are a couple of issues to bring to
the committee's attention
the first one is on page 10 of the
linked pdf
there's a comment regarding the fact
that the rules have been expired since
2018.
authority for the
administration of these professions
transferred from the department of
health and human services
to the oplc in 2015 and like i said the
rules expired
are get transferred in 2015 and the
rules have been expired since 2018. so
the committee may have some questions
about how licensing applications and
fees have been handled during that um
time period
um if you want i can go ahead and go
through uh the remaining comments or we
good morning lindsey courney executive
director office of professional ace
insurance certification
i think as the committee is no doubt
aware
the oplc has had some deficiencies in
the rule making process
that i think we've corrected with the
addition of staff and trying to
establish internal controls which
is why we were able to promulgate rules
for reflexology recently through this
proposal i will say i think there's
about
licensed reflexologists
i'm not aware of recent applications
that we've received that we have
attempted to enforce rules obviously
without rules in place those are not
enforceable so we would just adhere to
excuse me thank you mr chair uh do you
haven't
could you report on how many rules
expired rules you're suffering under at
the moment
so we do have a tracking sheet in place
my understanding is that
and tina can correct me if i'm wrong um
we're we're pretty up-to-date right now
we have a couple of rules for various
boards slated to expire in june but i
think they are um
they are underway
with regards to expired rules we do have
a couple of boards that have expired
rules that we're working on to get
before jail car as soon as possible and
we're working with the boards as quickly
well one of the concerns that that uh
those senior members of gelcar have and
representative mcguire and i and senator
reagan uh have
worked diligently to make the agencies
aware that their expired rules are not
rules they don't mean anything uh
supreme court ruled that way and then
there was a statute passed about what
six years ago or so to
make the stains same statement in
statute that they we can't be having
situations with expired rules out there
so
we are very concerned about what has
happened i hear this about since 2018
four years ago
um and so we're very concerned about
what has been going on with those with
those uh agencies and and departments
that have expired rules
thank you representative i i completely
share your concern and i will give you
an example something that came up
recently with the vet board um the vet
board has been working on rules since it
was transferred from agriculture
back in i think 2018 when i first came
on board
they had a rule making proposal in
process never finished it in part
because i think they couldn't make any
decisions
and so therefore their rules expired
related to continuing education we had
advised them very recently that they
couldn't enforce those continuing
education requirements which they're
aware of
and i understand a proposal is before
you but part of the issue is that while
oplc can provide administrative support
which obviously has been deficient in
the past we cannot require the boards to
make decisions and we cannot require
them to convene a quorum to actually
move the rules forward
reflex reflexology is different because
it's
an advisory board and it absolutely
should have been done sooner than than
today but um
but i do think that we've made the
necessary corrections in in internally
to make sure that that doesn't happen
again
so now is the time of year to start
proposing legislation
okay okay
the next issue to bring to your
attention is on page 13 of the linked
pdf
and this is a note regarding the fact
that the oplc has filed some rulemaking
to address fees in a plc 1002
you rain you may recall that um this
issue has come up previously
that um some of the rules some of the
board rules have been citing to
non-existent fees at plc1002 and so this
was just to let you know that um the
oplc has filed rulemaking to address
that concern
the next issue is on page 15 of the link
pdf and it's a minor editorial issue
it's just where the forms and the rule
texts aren't really lining up
like i said they're very minor
the form says mailing address whereas
the rule text says billing address
and there's just a minor difference in
the attestation where
here in the rural texas says rules but
on the form it says regulation
so um and then finally there is uh one
more issue on page 19 of the linked pdf
just scrolling down there
this one is around the cap
so there is um
this is about the fees and the fines the
statute has a cap of two thousand
dollars and some of these fines would
hit that cap during the first month of
non-compliance uh the rule doesn't talk
about the um doesn't address this
concern at all doesn't talk about the
cap so this could be fixed by having
some language in the rule that clearly
states that there is a two thousand
dollar cap
um other than that those are the
thank you mr chair i think that the
clarifying
that there is a
statutory limit of two thousand dollars
you could even put that up under under d
as part of the top
uh heading for the whole find schedule
in fact i would move that we
conditionally approve it provided that
you know it's out and said the semicolon
say come up to a limit of two thousand
dollars
or not to exceed two thousand not to
the agency
has has no objection to that
motion for approval by mcguire second by
gray
any discussion
all those in favor aye aye
and the rule carries
okay so this proposal makes changes to
the standards of practice for
pharmacists pharmacies manufacturers and
distributors licensed by the board
this item was postponed from the
previous meeting
and
that was to allow
the oplc to work with the board on a
conditional approval request and one has
been filed and it does address the
majority of the issues
there are a few still left to discuss
the first one begins on page
5 of the linked pdf
there's a note here down at the bottom
of the page
that
there's a large section here that's
being repealed
i have i don't think that they've
entered into any rule making um
to put this
you know section somewhere else in
another pharmacy rule
but this was to bring to your attention
and because once repealed
that section can't be enforced and so
the committee may have some questions
about the reasons and intent behind
repealing this section
um i can move on to the other ones if
you like
okay uh the next one i'll just scroll
down
it is on page um
10 of the linked pdf and here this is
just a clarity issue
the website there doesn't actually have
the control drug loss form
so that's why the comment is there
there's also a note down at the bottom
of the page to let you know that the
agency deleted a section on autumn
automated data processing systems but
that section is now part of another rule
making
the last issue involves comments
on the next page
and on page
i believe 20 of the linked pdf
and what this is about is that the rule
says that um permit holders need to have
a current
written break policy for when the
pharmacist in charge goes on break
and the statute also requires that there
be rules in place to en
around that issue
um
to specifically have a policy for the
super supervision of interns as well as
policy and procedures for when a
pharmacist goes on break but the
proposal has repealed that section
and um
so it's not entirely clear why that's
being repealed or whether or not that's
going to be part of
another rule making uh to address that
statutory requirement and
that's it
good morning i'm tina kelly with the
office of professional licensure and
certification
so to address the first issue on page
four
um the repeal of the larger section
that those rules are actually been moved
to institutional pharmacy practices
under ph 2300
and that has been
adopted
so everything from area sinks water size
of facility all of that is addressed
there
on page on the next one is the issue of
the website the form will be put on the
website as soon as it's approved and the
board adopts these rules because it i'm
not sure
with
the first forms but we're trying to get
all the forms into rule know that those
are the ones that are being used so the
one that you've got is the one that will
the next um one is um
the issue of
uh supervision of interns and breaks
that is all addressed in ph 303.02
what the pharmacy board is trying to do
with the changes to all of these roles
was to move things into different places
address things in the appropriate areas
so that is why you're seeing entire
sections being removed put other places
um
and they're trying to address
most of the time these rules were old so
they addressed pretty much sole
proprietors
now we have a lot of ins
corporations and that type so they're
trying to make these more inclusive so
anybody whether it's a sole proprietor
or a corporation can all follow the same
set of rules
so that's the goal but that is addressed
all good
motion
so
uh we had a situation four or five years
ago uh which um
i think you're probably aware of tinder
you've been around that longer than that
even uh with regard to breaks especially
for chain pharmacists uh and
we know we had a lot of testimony with
regard to error rate going up uh the
longer people don't have a break
especially a lunch break and people
working sometimes 12 and 13 hours with
no breaks
and that was you know the pharmacy board
was trying to do something about that
there was a lot of pushback of whether
they had the statutory authority whether
the you know pharmacy board did or not
so what is the current situation there
so i believe under 303.02 which i do not
have in front of me so i'm i'm speaking
from what i've talking to the board
member yesterday
was that those types of things are
addressed there so that there are
limits on the amount of hours a
pharmacist can work without a break or
um and things like that that's all in
303.02 so
even though it's been removed from here
it has been put into another section
okay
i'm okay yeah yeah okay you're still on
your microphone's stolen
sorry
yes yes um i see that in 70301 it does
require
eight no
arrests every no more than eight hours
is that
compatible with stricter than or less
strict than the rules in
sorry
um i believe they stayed tried to stay
consistent put in but put it in areas
where
it would be more applicable and without
looking back in that i
can't give you a different definitive
answer okay
excuse me um tina you said it was in 303
yeah that's that's what the board member
that i spoke to yesterday yeah i don't
see it and i've looked in our database
and i'm not seeing any recent
rule making around the issue so
tina when was the other one adopted
that i'm not sure of like i said i i
talked the board members do a lot of
their drafting so i talked to one of the
board members yesterday who provided me
with the information as i brought it up
we can look that up and and find you the
answer and give you a comparison of the
two rules
okay
fine i i moved to approve the rule
with the proviso that the
agency and the staff confirm that this
is compatible with other rules
second okay motion by mcguire second by
schmidt
any discussion
all those in favor aye aye
occupational therapists
okay um this proposal makes changes to
the rules for licensing of occupational
therapists and the proposal was
postponed from the last meeting because
the rule contains a citation to an
allied health rule for the fees
but the allied health role indicates
in the introductory section of that
rule that the schedule of
fees is for speech-language pathologists
and not for all allied health
professions
so
because the issue has come up several
times the committee wanted to postpone
to allow
oplc to work with the board to find out
whether or not the board intended into
to enter into rulemaking to address that
so the board of directors of the office
of licensed allied health professionals
met on
5 12
and
i gave them proposed language to list
all of the boards within allied health
so that was very clear that the
fees applied to all the boards and they
have approved that
um there is one other fee that they
wanted to wait and that's that's
something completely different
and it's pending the addition of sp
hearing care providers so we just have
to get that on that one rule um
one fee the approval of the speech board
once that's done i'll be filing rule
making
okay
that's everything that's everything sir
motion
move to approve
that
motion by mcguire second by bursting
any discussion all those in favor aye
aye
passenger tramway safety board
mr chairman yes uh the vote that just
occurred that was a conditional approval
this is passenger tramway's safety rules
um there are several clarity and
legislative intent comments mainly with
regards to the forums mentioned in the
rules because they've not been filed yet
with the committee staff for review
excuse me
and there was a issue
there was an issue
brought to the committee staff attention
after the comments were finished
regarding the possible creation of
licenses which may cause a lack of
authority comment um however um
i believe the agency is prepared to take
a preliminary objection so that we can
have time to work these issues out
fine in that case i move to object to
the rule on the grounds that it
creates
actually two new licenses at least i'm
not sure there's if there's more but
there are at least two new licenses that
are defined in the rule
second
so your um objection would be based on
staff comments and on the possible lack
of authority for the licenses
yes 541a requires explicit authority to
create a license
and
i don't believe they have it
no i was just asking if you wanted to
okay we have a motion in a second
are you clear on
sorry good good morning my name is march
multiyani
i've been working with the passenger
tramway safety board
[Music]
with their rule making
um
the
the forms we did provide to ols and i
think that a lot of the comments we can
address the board is next meeting in
june so i believe that most of the staff
comments can be addressed satisfactorily
to the board with regards to the most
we don't i don't believe that we
necessarily agree that the board is
creating a license because the
board is given the authority to
incorporate the the standards in order
to regulate the ski
areas
and it's
the board has incorporated by reference
the ansi standard
which you have in your meeting packet
which does
um reference the qualified wire
inspectors
um
and therefore i'm not sure that we'll be
able to address it satisfactorily to to
the committee but we might be able to
explain it
i would i have to agree with the agency
martyrs correct it's unclear if there is
a license to to committee staff as well
but the preliminary objection will give
us time to to look into that and
determine
if if it you know explain the situation
to you and make sure that there isn't a
license being created if you look at the
bottom of page seven it says qualified
wire rope inspector means an individual
who is acceptable to the board to
inspect wire ropes that says that any
person who is inspecting wire ropes
must be given
approval by the board
if you want to say that it's a person
who is
has been qualified
according to
federal standards or national or
national sin that's something different
but you're changing from the
owner of the wire as picking somebody to
do the inspection to saying that the
board has to approve
such a person and that means it's a
license yes i agree the um
the rule does incorporate some some i
believe it's federal
information and the statute is quite
vague so um
i that's what i'm saying i need some
more time to
to
look through that so i can explain it
better okay
i'm agreeable with that
okay and you sir please tell us who you
are hi uh my name is briggs lockwood and
i am the chief uh tramway inspector for
the new hampshire department of safety i
apologize for being late
can you shed any light on the
um i'm not sure exactly what you've been
speaking about but um
the
the standard that we've adopted for
years
requires that
a a y rope expert
inspects the wire ropes annually and
since the beginning
when
new hampshire first
made
had an rsa that was passed in 1960
the new hampshire is required
that the person who claims to be an
expert
shall submit their credentials to the
board and the board would approve them
and put them on a list so that as far as
i know there hasn't been any change to
to the way
we've been doing that
since the early days before my time so i
think what i'm not sure i understand
what the question is
procedurally but i think it nothing
seems to in my view has changed we still
require that if a person wants to be
considered an expert to inspect wire
ropes in new hampshire they submit their
credentials the tramway board reviews
them approves them and puts them on a
list and who issues the credentials
the person brings those uh there's a
list of requirements in our rules that
say if you
the board shall approve them if they
bring in if you've got i know the rules
in front of me the
two five years experience or there's a
so many inspections completed uh how
many years experience a letter of
recommendation from a wire rope
manufacturer a person brings those to
the board
the board reviews them and says yep you
you're
on
mike
in 1985 and 86 i was a legal intern at
the department of safety and reviewed
rules in including passenger tramway and
but i believe at that time 541a did not
explicitly require that every license be
statutorily authorized i believe you're
correct
yes it seems like we've defined the
issue and with the preliminary objection
i think it's time for the
department to take action during
the period of time until this comes up
the next
okay in the interim
if there's anybody that even issues
a license
to
there's no other entity that i know of
uh we could do it ourselves as a state
you know i think well that's what we're
questioning if we need to establish the
license
okay okay
so
you have a
you have a motion for preliminary
objection and i believe there was a
second although i don't know who the
second was it was representative lange
yeah
oh
okay any further discussion
edith
i just want to make sure that as we're
looking at these we are aware that there
are more tramways now unless
this is defined as at cannon mountain
there seem to be
trams
at
omni mount washington other places right
i think that total no we're talking
about all ski lifts when we tall tramway
so all ski lifts right so the number is
pretty stable you know um
there's construction seasons like this
one that are um pretty busy
but um
if you looked at it over a long period
of time i think
we we aren't seeing a big increase but
there's 175 or so
of them right now it's been that way for
a while
thank you very much
okay you've heard the discussion all
all right this rule is an interim rule
regarding ems letters of concern
and it was filed as a result of chapter
205 of the laws of 2021 which allows the
commission the commissioner excuse me to
issue a letter of concern in lieu of a
license suspension
um the only
substantive comment is on page four of
the rule text
and the concern is that the text states
that a suspension may be deferred or may
be rescinded and this language allows
for oral rule making
because of the lack of criteria for when
these would or would not happen
however
even though the court current language
is unclear um
and
causes a legislative intent issue this
is an interim rule and so these issues
issues could be fixed when the agency
goes to regular rulemaking
that process because interim rules only
motion by laying second by mcguire to
approve the interim rule
discussion
seeing none all those in favor aye any
opposed
department of environmental services
okay so this is air related standards
for new and modified facilities for air
pollutants the proposal makes changes to
the rules for those standards and it
impacts municipal solid waste landfills
there is a one issue to discuss
which you'll see on the top of the page
on page seven of the linked pdf
the state has a delegation agreement
with the apa and the rule is being
updated to incorporate new and revised
epa standards palmergated since 2017.
there should be also a linked
agency
response to comments and in that
document the agency states that the
standards are already in place
and
essentially that
they're already in effect and so the
proposal doesn't impose any new
requirements on any existing sources in
the state
so that's the issue and
the department you know may be able to
explain that a little more
yes mr chair i i find it disingenuous of
the agency to say that we've been
incorporating these standards for the
last two years and therefore it's not a
new requirement it's a new requirement
since the last time the rules were
updated if i understand you correctly
and therefore it's a new requirement
like i said i think that the agency can
explain a little more my understanding
is that um it's uh already a standard
that a lot of the standards were already
industry-wide but like i said pam monroe
is here and can probably answer your
questions
pam monroe for environmental services
so
what happens is epa promulgates these
what are called the mission guidelines
and that's the the 2014 date is is the
date of the promulgation and so any
source that is
is in existence at that time is an
existing source
then there's a process by which the
the epa promulgates a federal plan
the federal plan then makes those
emission guidelines enforceable
that federal plan was litigated at the
federal level
and it went into effect in june of 2021
so
in order for the department now so the
existing sources are subject to the
federal requirements now the department
has always taken the approach that
we
want to regulate new hampshire sources
instead of them having to deal with epa
so the plan went into effect in june of
this action will incorporate by
reference the federal standards the
federal
um
the federal plan so that the state can
now enforce the requirements
against
with new hampshire sources to work with
them
to comply with the standards
and i apologize if our papers weren't
clear enough on that
well if you want to say that the
it it's a new requirement in the rule if
you say it's due to the
federal requirements which you have
our constitution forbids us from just
casually adopting
federal rules or regulations that have
not been approved by
the the legislature or its delegates
namely jail car so you can't just say to
everybody okay the fed
there's a new new federal um federal
requirement that everybody has to
has to agree to you have to come to it
with rulemaking and and it is
in the rule it's a new requirement
that's exactly why we're here
it's
this action so currently
these sources are subject to federal
requirements epa can enforce those
federal requirements against
sources in new hampshire that are
subject to them this action
we're coming before you to adopt those
standards so that the state
can enforce them you're correct we
cannot do that now
second
motion by schmidt second by senator
whitley
discussion
all those in favor
aye
okay
all right the next is board of education
the learn everywhere program it's 20 21
um
excuse me
the conditional approval request for
this proposal has eliminated all but one
comment
and the comment appears on the last page
and deals with text on page 8 of the
rule
it's edie
1407.02
a the text reads as follows says
notwithstanding ed 306 schools shall
accept at least one third and may accept
as much as 100 percent if approved by
the superintendent of the total number
of credits required for high school
graduation if requested by a student
pursuant to see below
now this some of you may remember has
come around before
so in
2019 the gel car voted six to four
to do a final objection to what was then
2019 5 on the same rule
the objections were based on
legislative intent and uh
a lack of authority
of the board the jail car also
voted to do six to four voted for a
joint resolution which went
uh back to the senate
to clarify the authority of the board
uh that was senate uh joint resolution
one during the 2020 uh legislative
session it was voted ought to pass in
the senate and it was laid on the house
of the table in the house where it died
after that the
the agency was allowed to promulgate the
rule which they did over in
august of 2020 it was adopted over a
final objection which means that the
currently the burden of proof is on the
board
to establish that the part objected to
is within the authority delegated
um
at this time that final objection still
stands and as far as gel car staff knows
there have been no challenges um in a
court or um in any way of this uh rule
that was objected to and so
essentially it's the same the same
language and as i maintained the last
time this came around um
there may be an issue of lack of
authority and there may be an issue of
legislative intent that is up to the gel
card to determine
and um you can now at this time either
preliminary do a preliminary objection
issue a conditional approval if you have
specific language that you want to
change or you may vote to approve
the rule if you approve the rule this
would take away the final objection from
before and flip the burden of proof back
onto the plaintiff
which is what your objection and
approval does
so if the agency
would like to to discuss as well but i
know some of you remember this was the
same issue from before so if any if you
have any questions you want me to
explain more i can um because i know not
all of you were here last time mr chair
i i want to move a preliminary objection
because of the uh all the issues that
were just raised nothing has changed
since 2019 so
um i would i would you know be
interested to hear why nothing has
changed since 2019 but i want to move a
preliminary injection objection based on
the comments that the staff made thank
you
uh welcome commissioner and
for the record chris bond senior
assistant attorney general uh here on
behalf of the department of education
okay
and identifiers
great so
did you want me to respond to the
comments i wasn't sure if there was a
question specific question in there no i
just made the motion thank you yeah
okay
so you heard the staff comments
go ahead
is there a motion that you're responding
to or do you want me to respond
so i made the motion based on the fact
that what we have in front of us exactly
is exactly the same as what we saw in
2019 and you know the procedural
things that happened after that so i'm
curious even though there was a you know
a final objection and everything that
happened why there isn't anything
different about the rules that are
before us
yeah so we made excuse me commissioner
mr chair we have a motion with no second
and without a second the motion dies
great so thank you so what has happened
since we um were here before jail car
previously
is that we have implemented the program
so we now have 15 learn everywhere
programs that have been approved in the
state
and you have students who are engaging
in instructional materials in fact i was
on a phone call before i came in
of students who have completed a program
at the new hampshire institutes of
science in order to
earn credits
and so we are moving forward with the
program as it is and as we began the
implementation of that program we saw
there were some technical fixes in the
rules that we wanted to do so we're
bringing this rule before the body for
that purpose
we believe in the letter that was
provided to you
in the
package of information that we have
addressed
the jail car concerns that have been
raised and you will notice that um
the gel cart attorneys were very precise
in their language i said there may have
been a concern we believe there is not
a constitutional problem there is not a
rule problem associated with this and
follow-up
i just wanted to ask the jail car staff
if you believe that all the concerns
so my
purpose is not to make the determination
of a
judge
in a court of law so
i can say that there may be
a lack of authority and there may be
um issues of um legislative intent
issues
but i cannot definitively
answer that it's it's up to the gel card
to determine that
representative mcguire yes thank you i'd
like to ask
the commissioner if he has taken any
steps to obtain legislative
clarification
of this issue
um so there was a bill that was in the
house i don't know what the status of it
is right now that was continuing to
further clarify the legislation towards
mr chairman
i do know that representative ladd was
just a point of clarification i
understand exactly what we're talking
about the issue resolve revolving that
we're discussing right now is basically
whether or not the board of education
has the authority to say that one third
of the credits shall be granted thr can
may be granted through
[Music]
at a request of a student may be granted
towards graduation and whether or not
they have that authority if that
authority or granting credit solely and
strictly relies with amongst the school
board or school district is that my
understanding of this conversation
that's correct the
the issue was whether or not um the
board
could mandate
one-third be taken by
um be accepted by the
the schools because the statute
appears that it may have
separated out those those authorities um
part of it to the school board the
school boards and part of it to the the
agency the the board of education um and
that was the the question of where does
that line lie
and so we had addressed that issue and
we continue to assert that when you read
the statute where it talks about uh
relative to the approval of alternative
programs for granting credit leading to
graduation that
that
ability to grant credit leading to
graduation does the best the authority
in the board as well the letter that was
laid out to you as well as the testimony
that was previously provided and
legislative history on this
demonstrates in fact that uh that was
the original intent of that bill and is
receiving further clarification through
the legislative process
mr chair
thank you
thank you mr chair so i um just going
back to jack carr's
staff
comments it's more than just the
authority if you look on um their
comments there's a a problem that they
have a a potential problem they think
that um it's contrary to legislative
intent
um
uh in two different ways so it's both um
you know i the my motion for preliminary
injunction is based on two different
potential bases i mean we only need one
and there are two here um the fact that
the
authority was exceeded and that it's
contrary to legislative intent so we
have
two out of the potential four bases in
fact we only need one so that's the
basis of my motion thank you
well so what i would tell you is that
we've uh responded to the other
objection as well i was responding to
representative lang's uh question
specifically but we have addressed both
god yes i noticed that was house bill
1329 which was voted
uh on the consent unanimously by the
education committee to be killed because
the state board has rules
which
says that they aren't going to yeah well
that's
that's the legislative intent we don't
need the law because we have rules which
i'm sorry i didn't notice it at the at
the time but it was
uh if i man
go ahead
i just wanted to
reiterate that you know the department's
position is that this the legislation is
clear and the intent is clear obviously
that uh we don't agree with the ols
staff on that point but i just want to
read
the the language of rsa 193 e2a
roman numeral 5b
it says the state board of education
shall adopt rules pursuant to rsa 541a
relative to the approval of alternative
programs for granting credit leading to
graduation so um i assume hearing that
the the reference to the state board has
rules might have been a reference to
that statutory authority that gives the
board the authority to do that
right and the original
confusion
was because of the paragraph before that
and reading the language of the statute
together
again
greater minds have differed over clearer
okay we have a motion from senator
whitley
would you restate your your object
thank you uh mr chair yup so i move a
preliminary injunction based on the
significant uh issues raised
by
the oll staff who as we all know are you
know the most conscientious
folks i believe in the state house and
you know i just want to say you know um
of course i you know i recognize that
students learn differently and but i
also think that it's important for
schools to
you know retain local control over what
learning counts um towards graduation
credit so
hopefully the department will work with
ols staff
to address the concerns that have been
raised you know
three years ago
there's been ample time to to do that so
hopefully this this preliminary
objection based on two different bases
again there are four potential bases we
have two here so i do feel like it is
our obligation um under our authority
the gel cards authority under under the
statute to to issue this preliminary
injunction and let them you know work
together to get a product that really
works for everyone thanks further
discussion
tim
thank you mr chair again i think
section 5b is extremely clear when it
says the word shall adopt rules
relative the approval of alternative
programs for granting credit leading to
graduation so that clearly gives the
agency rulemaking authority to set some
parameters i think they were
conservative in choosing one-third as
the as the minimum standard so i i'm
any other discussion
on senator whitley's
motion
edith
the chair votes now senator ward
and senator yes yes
okay the motion fails mr chair
move to a proof
second
discussion on
mr chair thank you i mean i think this
is doing a big disservice to the many
attorneys on the jail car staff i mean i
respect your analysis but i i would
always defer i'm a lawyer myself but
even in this case i would defer to our
our staff um
all lawyers all went to law school are
telling us there's problems so i'm
really sad to see this i think this
really uh interferes with the
credibility of gel car that we're doing
this
further discussion
later
the fact that it has not been
adjudicated i think uh leaves the matter
up in the air in my mind as well
uh the fact that it hasn't been
challenged uh uh is you know
the the
the
argument that
senator whitley
annunciated a while back uh has merit in
this particular situation i think uh
because
to the degree that there was an
objection to begin with
uh and that uh
it has not been adjudicated leaves it up
in the air and i would have preferred if
if the
committee uh sorry if the head board of
education had come back to us with
uh
the department of education had come
back to us with some
recognition and and acceptance of that
and some change
so i think it's still leaves up in the
air and it has not been adjudicated so i
don't think it's resolved
and jacquard staff is a combat legal
authority uh i'm going to go with that
representative mcguire yes thank you i'm
agency apparently was
working with the chair of the education
committee to clarify this so that it's
not conflict
and the
and they decided that it wasn't
necessary because it's in the rule and i
think we need to train our committee
chairs better so that they know that is
that the rule does not trump the law
committee staff is actually working on
some of those trainings
to do just that thank you
any other discussion
representative
yes
no
sure votes yes senator
yes
no
do we have any other
business to come before the committee
if if not mr chair
we might want to reschedule next
next month's meeting
okay
mike uh that was what i was going to
speak to uh for the newer committee
members traditionally gelcar has met on
fridays the third friday for the first
half of the year during session and then
on the third thursday the remainder of
the year uh this year session is ending
somewhat early so
and there should not be many meetings in
june so there was interest in moving the
june meeting to thursday however since
the committee had voted on its schedule
at the beginning of the year i think it
second motion is to move the june
meeting from
friday to thursday
all in favor aye
and we'll cancel the continued meeting
so that will make the next meeting on
okay
we are adjourned before the bagpipes
right
thank you for beating the bagpipe
deadline
was there an attorney
was there an adjournment
yes
you